this is what the global supply chain
squeeze looks like in practice fifteen
thousand packs of plywood from china
coming ashore in portsmouth pallet by
pallet they should come in steel
containers but a worldwide shortage
means it takes seven weeks instead of
seven days to unload
when you add brexit covered and
container shortages i've never seen it
i've been in the industry 35 years never
seen anything like this i think people
will struggle
to get the christmas presents for the
children ships are full containers are
either moving or not moving
from certain areas
there's no
there's no spare capacity in the
industry
to stop consumer shortages and business
disruption getting even worse the
government is again postponing new
brexit customs checks
since the uk left the eu in january 2020
there have been no physical border
checks or safety certificates required
for agricultural and animal imports from
the continent they were due to start in
april before being delayed until october
and now won't be imposed until july next
year
portico's customs agency has taken on
dozens of staff to handle the new red
tape they say customers and consumers
underestimate
we can do all the documentation side of
things but we're not responsible for the
checks
so if the if they don't have the
resource and the infrastructure in place
it will impact on the supply chain of
food
this is or will be portsmouth's brand
new border control point but like many
brexit facilities around the country
it's not ready yet one of the reasons
here is a shortage of the materials they
need to finish it materials that come in
at port just like that one over there
brexit minister lord frost says he's
being pragmatic but has ruled out
agreeing a veterinary standards deal
with the eu that would remove the need
for many checks at all the pandemic
might have been a factor in terms of
making it a little bit more difficult to
go through all these steps but i think
the key factor here was when we started
preparing and i think we started a bit
too late
british exporters to the eu already
faced the costs of full customs checks
on their goods a brexit burden their
european competitors will now not have
to carry for another nine months paul
kelso sky news in portsmouth